Facebook have you heard about that thing
I just saw actually that Mark Zuckerberg
today they announced he made 2.2 billion
dollars in 2012 so you know a lot of
people are on that Facebook they just
lifted their violent video ban and this
has a lot to do with beheadings so
basically people were posting all these
beheadings that were happening all over
the world mostly in the Middle East and
then in May they banned it and they've
been reviewing their policy and as of
yesterday they have lifted the ban and
now you can see the headings on Facebook
again but we've got a quote from
Facebook spokesman people share videos
of these events on Facebook to condemn
them if they were being celebrated or
the actions in them encouraged our
approach would be different we want to
draw a distinction between users who
want to share events that are important
to them and videos that are being
celebrated and shared for sadistic
pleasure
that's Matt Steinfeld from Facebook all
right so they're making a clear
distinction between I guess bad but
headings and and good beheadings or
celebratory the headings or something I
guess this sort of goes to the nature of
what is Facebook and should it be just
this open source thing that anyone can
put anything on what do you make on this
about this flip yeah I mean I think that
you know it's interesting that they
would take such a firm stance on
violence when they've been so you know
equally firm against like you know
nudity and breastfeeding that whole cup
yeah we're gonna get to that yeah but I
mean I guess it's good if they if they
want to if they're allowing people to
condemn violence in their own you know
weird way I personally don't want to see
any of that on my facebook newsfeed
really so but what about your Twitter
feed would you be more okay with it on
Twitter because I think this does go to
the what why do we use these things and
how we use differently I mean the thing
is I know that it exists I mean I guess
like you know not everybody is as
informed but um but yeah I mean I think
that uh I think it's okay I think it's
okay yeah all right well let's take a
look at some of the other things that
Facebook has banned right now they're
banning nudity drug use pornography
promotion of eating disorders any video
that condones violence images of
breastfeeding only if child is actively
nursing
no nipples allowed I didn't make this up
yeah that's actually true oh and here's
this is just fantastic let's look at
this image of Kylie Minogue
they banned this image of her she's
holding a bear there and as you can see
they said we do not allow photos that
contain nudity drug use or violence now
it appears that the microphone looks
like the Bears penis I suppose I haven't
seen a bear penis before but I guess
that's what's happening here and
Facebook actually took that picture down
so does this just sort of show the
subjectivity and how stupid when you
have these big rules for everybody on
something as big as Facebook how stupid
these rules are unless that did that
turn you on in any way I like that you
know we had a story on on riot the other
day that was about the London Museum of
Art is having a new exhibition of
Japanese wood printing block printing
from the 1800s and there was one of a
painting of a naked woman and they
pulled it off they banned me for a day
they banned our whole the minute they
pulled riot down for a day and it was a
painting yeah from the 18th century on a
like a beautiful piece of fine art and
it was frustrating to me because I think
you know was part of goes back to a part
of our culture that is so afraid to show
nipples on a feed but can absolutely
show you no violence and and and to me I
would rather see nipples on my feed than
blood any day
right absolutely speaking of nipples on
Facebook I remember a couple months ago
there was a portrait a painting of Bea
Arthur that was gonna that was sold for
like 1.1 million dollars on Sotheby's
and they put the picture on there and
they took that down so it's even a
painting I don't think anyone's really
looking at BRS painted nipples in a
sexual way no it's it's totally absurd
are you max I'm not your might
yeah no I do think it's it's ridiculous
that you can't show you know tasteful
nudity on Facebook right so what do you
guys think it should be open for
everything I mean if so when they're
showing these beheading things usually
it's to expose something awful that's
happening the last time that I
specifically remember it was with the
Syrian rebels beheading some people and
and it turned out maybe it wasn't the
rebels and I don't think but shouldn't
Facebook just be open sort of for what
we all want to whatever it is no we what
you you select your friend
so what I also don't know what the point
of it is I mean if you're showing it I
also don't know how you tell if you're
condoning it or you're celebrating or it
statistic in the first place I mean for
us with our new site we spend a lot of
time at riot like saying look should we
post this picture should we not post
this picture do people want to see it
and we have a young audience our posts
go up on Facebook yeah so we're really
sensitive to that and people call us out
all the time if we put a Facebook post
that has a really bloody image on it
that will happen with the Boston
Marathon I think a lot of people trying
to figure out how we show those images
there yeah
I always try to be sensitive to it
because if there's not at least an
action of how you can help that person
then what then it is sadistic in that
ways you know yeah what would you rather
be open for everything just for the
because you're selecting your friends
yeah people that you know that are
seeing it are it is a cultivated and
sort of right I would never say that
they should censor you know anything
especially if you know the pictures
depicting violence do don't condone
violence in any way you know they're
they're being used to sort of say how
awful it is but I personally you know
like I see a lot of things on my
newsfeed about you know from animal
rights activists that are like pictures
of animals you know undergoing
vivisection and things like that and I
it turns me off you know I don't think
that that's the way to rally people
around your cause by using you know
inflammatory you know graphic imagery
you know it's just not you ever have
that watch those faces of death videos
when you were kid when I was like 12 my
mom is not happy I had one friend who
always wanted to have a sleepover and
play those videos the night like I
didn't want to hang out with that kid
even where he was the creepy one I would
just watch like child's play or
something up and I wanted to watch those
videos right so I unn friended him in
real life that's so crazy if you don't
know what faces of death night it was
bait it was Lily was real killing yeah
they showed on tape I don't know I was
having sleepovers watching lunch is too
perfect
very weird hey guys don't forget the
Reuben reports brought to you by Cooper
comm they've got up to 75% off pet
treats toys and more and if you use code
RR you can get another 20% off that's a
lot off there is a link in the
description right down below code RR 20%
off make your pet happy